Alon Matas
thank you for being here
thank you for having me
all right
so
better help, Corona online therapy
we only have 20 minutes
but I want to talk about this for an hour
what is better help?
and then let's dive into why this is so relevant
and March of 2020
it's already April
so better help is the largest online
counseling service
was wide and started six years ago
we have a network of forewords 7000
licensed therapists nationwide
and we connect people who are looking for
mental health help
with one of these licensed therapists
based on their needs and preferences,
where they can go to
a counseling online
pretty similar to the one they would have
in a brick and mortar
but with four options of communication
messaging, which is a synchronous, you
send
a message to your therapist any time you
want it
to be like e-mail, get a response,
usually seeing you day after
or you schedule like sessions over
phone, video or chat
we have around a little over
2 million interactions every month
or months in Corona
definitely
it's anything but usual
as people need more,
we need more therapy and help given the
stress, anxiety and even loneliness with
shelter-in-place
coming to most states
And of course, the inability to actually
go to see a therapist
in the office if you wanted to
OK
so way too many questions am
I have to go back a little bit
now, you're not coming from the therapy
world
you're not a psychologist
and did you even come from healthcare,
general, and before?
no,
not at all
how did you get to build this?
so I'm coming from a consumer products
background of
being in this space for
18 years now, of interacting
with consumers on marketplaces and
different kinds of services
and I'm not coming from counseling
I'm not coming from health care
there's a whole debate about whether
farmers should come from the domain from
outside of the domain
definitely lots of examples, Uber
or BMB and you name it, of
better health help their verticals and hope
that were founded by people
who came outside of their domain
there are some advantages that leave
fresh thinking,
usually more line of thought that
it's aligned with what consumers want
rather than what the system is used
to provide, and maybe convenience the
system by the traditional way
obviously we have therapists
on the team and we, all the clinical staff
I'm not making any clinical decisions
whatsoever,
but our concerned
from day one was we wanted to create
something that people actually wanted
people use because
instead we argue with therapy
and that's not Corona related is,
it's a huge deal of a lot of people, but
most people actually don't use that
so you broke your leg
or you coughing today
you're going to see a doctor in
90% plus of the cases
but most people who struggle with mental
health, even
very significant struggles, will
avoid going to therapy
so you have research shows that you have
around 25% at any given time,
has a serious mental health issue
that should be
addressed by a professional
but at any given time, very few of them
would actually go to sleep
why? because if it's expensive, it's
inaccessible
it's inconvenient
I experienced this myself when,
socially unacceptable sometimes
there is a lot of stigma
and I experience myself when I thought,
you know, maybe in the last
days of my previous company for the
better health care to be, I want
see a therapist and I thought, OK,
that's that should be easy
it was anything but easy
so it's it's really
a very, very needed service therapy as a
whole
that can change people's lives
it's really amazing how people's I can
change
and sometimes pretty quickly, with the
help of a true professional
that is train
in and has the right expertise,
but still so few people actually use them
so our approach and that may be
a different approach by the company,
especially the last two, three years,
was not to disrupt therapy,
not say, oh, we've got to do AI, we're not
going to do about it
it's a whole different way of therapy,
which is the exact opposite approach
that we want
therapy is a tried and true science that
is studied
and proved over so many years
we're going to give is a,
as it is, it's the same therapist that
you see in brick and mortar
it's the same type of
interactions and it goes
what we're changing, what we're
disrupting is
the delivery mechanism
so it's the way people communicate with a
therapist
make it more accessible, more convenient
and eventually also more affordable
OK, so I'm one of the biggest advocates, I think
in the world for
four therapy, practicing and myself with
a professional
and I believe that every person in the
world needs to see
a therapist because it's having the
subjective
persona that's able to help you reflect
on what
you're feeling and believing
I think it's just it's a privilege
and that that we have
and unfortunately, in most people in the
world can't afford
it or it's not accessible
and so what you're doing is amazing,
but you're also making a lot of money
I'm sure you are
millions of, you said 2 million sessions,
2 million sessions a month
and I'm guessing
I remember that what was the last
number that you shared
with me and the total number of sessions
that were through better help
so far, we had around 65 million of messages,
video calls, phone calls,
insane
how do you balance this idea that you're
creating a business that is, you know,
at the end of it, it's it's a good business
it's social good
you're helping so many people at the same
time you're making money
do you find any contradiction there?
do is, people challenge you on that
sometimes?
there's always the notion of, oh, you're
making you know, you're making
money of people's misery
but that's, I think, coming
to so many professions from doctors to
mechanics
Yeah, I can make money when
your car breaks
and doctors make money when your body
breaks and where,
that's why people hate insurance
companies, right?
Yeah, it's, we provide a solution
and so I definitely feel
comfortable, especially that we make
it much more affordable
but yes, mental health is a touchy
topic, I think
and smarter people said it before me
that the 4th profit model
is when you can make it work
is actually what brings the most value
to mankind
maybe it's a fortune
that's the way it is
but that's that's reality
so if you can make a sustainable business
and make good sometime
that's perfect
But we do recognize that we have
you know
extra responsibility here, which was
why, for example,
we have a very extensive
financial aid program
so if you sign up for a service, if you can't
afford that service,
we provide
financial aid in very serious discounts
we keep paying therapists the same as
therapies are
unaware that even you may be getting
financial aid because
we think that they should focus under on
their job
and we subsidize, we give kind of a free service
to, you know, when there is a time of
nature disaster or in the time of Corona
we also give some groups a
free or very discounted service
so we try to help wherever we can
but yes, we're a full profit corporation
Yeah
we're also need to support the therapies that,
I think it's I think it's completely right
I mean, I completely agree with that
and I I love this this idea of
a win win situation and then really
creating incentives for both groups to
maximize on it
and you know I got to start working recently
at Hippo Insurance
and I get to see firsthand
you insurance company
and, you know, just the word insurance
makes some people vomit
but all of a sudden, you're seeing a new
type of company come up and
really try to think, how can we make
their user experience
better so that they don't see us as the
enemy, but as a friend
and I think I'm learning a lot through
that experience and I'm really
making analogies to what's happening
with better help
and that's why I also really love what
you guys are doing
and now,
anything that you provide
value to the end user, that's
something we get every day,
sometimes five, sometimes 10 these days,
many more than that
e-mails from people,
I see what you're sharing
change or stage of their lives
this is really the big joy
of coming to work here
a lot of companies try to bring value,
but when you
do that in such a direct way
ou actually change something very
fundamental in someone's
life as someone like that.
that's really amazing
and that keeps us very motivated every day
I mean, Alon, you can literally fill up
your whole
wall with tweets of better help save my life
I see that every day on Facebook,
that's done that Really?
I don't see that about many
companies that term
something saved my life
you know, something made me happier or
something was tasty
something helped me enjoy movies better,
but something saved my life
I think that's pretty special
now we're in April where hopefully
soon at the peak of Corona
and how is this how is this affecting
better help?
what's happening to
the therapy world where
now all therapists have to move online, basically
so we see several things happening
first of all, are existing members
the people that's been in therapy
with us maybe
for months and some of them even years,
definitely use a service warning
you see that in the data, our model,
we mentioned that better models, really,
the consumer is paying a flat fee, a
monthly fee
and with that fee, they can interact with
the counselors as much as they like
over text and messages as they need
and they can have a weekly live session
of a fun video chat
so it's kind of a flexible model that
use the service more or less as need
without worrying on the financials of a
specific session
so we see a lot of people just use the
service more
Right
and we're very happy that we can help
them this time
we also have an influx of a lot of new
members
the number of new people that sign up
with us
and so therapy with us has doubled
these February-March to specific
people with stress and anxiety,
which are things that are relevant to
Corona virus
double then compared to a February March
of last year
so that's also destined to to the great in
unlike maybe other
verticals where you have a problem
of the months sucking up supply cannot
accommodate that or you have more
supply Now that demand in
you know artists specifically
for this crisis is actually played
out pretty well because
a lot more people need therapy, but also
a lot of therapists are now available to provide
more services
so we see, firstly we see a lot more patients of
therapist who wants to work with us,
but also the current therapists
are opening their availability more
because we have a lot of therapies
I just think Better Help have a
private practice to work in a school,
in an agency
and of course, now everything is
very different
so, yes, we have a lot more demand,
but also supply
improved significantly
so we're we're pretty,
pretty in good shape to accommodate an
ease of both sides of.
Yeah, I mean, you know, every second
article that I read is about
how tech startups are firing
vehemently across the board
and then I go on Facebook and Alon Matas
we're hiring aggressively
please refer to us
I think over the last week we hired like
six people,
in the company of how many?
in the company of how many people?
at Better Help 70 or maybe I don't know, 75
so you increased by almost 10 %
Yeah
now everybody is talking percentages
Yeah. and we also tried to make it to meet
the people who are infected now
so for example, one of the
maybe bigger startups and so-called I'm
sure now
a mass layoff
last week, we made a webinar
a couple days ago with a whole
department that
just got shut down and offered
all of them to start a Fast-Track
process
because we know an , for me like I
want to come across is someone taking
advantage of the situation
but for all for us, you know, always
wanting
now you interview someone
and they look great and they have all
the qualifications and everything
you always having at the back of your mind
OK, so what? Why do
you leave your previous workplace or
why were you let go?
and that's always kind of a sticking point
I need to understand the story
here
it's actually very simple
Yeah, my department got shut down
it's a great starting to get company even
over hours
so is it awesome? I mean,
it's it's terrible
but they're now they're kicking people
looking for a job
and the fact is, looking for a job has
nothing to
do with her performance
Yeah.
or they could please just situational
interesting
I kind of assume that they are top
performers because they were in
their own startup
so we'll still make an interview process
and we'll
make some hiring process
but it's a much more faster thing to do
with a lot
more confidence with your situation
so what's going to happen a year from now?
A you know, I'm looking at people having
weddings over zoom, funerals over zoom and
let alone so therapy obviously, what's
going to happen in
a year with online relationships and
communication.
you know, I just started planning my
eleven year old birthday present today
it's a good thing it's not a bar mitzvah.
You know, you have a year like day.
I don't know, like I don't have a
crystal ball thinking a lot of
I think and in this week, I don't know when this
is going to be in this week.
I think there is a
some kind of sudden realization
that this is not a binary situation
where it
will just, you know, we're now shut down
in the announcement of a moment
we'll go back to normal.
now people starting to realize that it's
going
probably going to be a gradual process
with a lot of checks and balances and
ups and downs
and pullbacks and restrictions
and that's open and actually opening up a
lot of questions
of how things are going to look like
I don't think, you know, face to face is
doomed forever
I think we'll definitely go back to that
and that's great
I think online is but definitely
should
be the path of a space for some people
that feel more comfortable
some patients are also best addressed with
a space
also, refer people in normal times
a pretty significant percent, people who
sign up to Better Help and tell them
actually only counseling is not
a great fit for you or your situation,
or maybe your severity
you should go face to face and we provide
referrals and resources
so it should definitely be back and
should be back
but I think a lot of people
just like with, you know
web conferencing and doing meeting
online and
working remotely
were forced to experience other things and
find out that, you know what, that's
actually works
pretty well better than I expected
so I think if if we prove that we
can provide the quality of service that
people expect and get in traditional
format, then it's definitely going to
have a long
term and impact on the US
but are we are we doomed to
go full virtual?
so I'm thinking about, you know, my
generation, the one after me
and I mean, if we look at it in 20 years,
do you really I mean, I'm looking at you
as an expert on virtual relationship,
Right, virtual communication and, you
know, therapy
you could suggest that it's one of the
most intimate relationships
that you could form with another with a
person, let alone a professional
and you're showing that it's possible and
can still be adequate, well virtual
so do you think  that's where we're headed worse
at some point we're just gonna take
it for granted that everything is
virtual and doing this physically
will be kind of a weird and out of the norm?
twenty years is a long, long time
you can look at what happened with retail
retailers that only suffered a lot with
the rise of online
and Amazon and e-retailers,
but it still exists in
still a huge portion of
commerce is done in physical retail
I think it's
always going to have to have both
maybe not in the same proportion we have now
and of course, it's up to us to prove that
it works in now
you know, when we started six years ago,
it was a theory
and then we started getting feedback from
users and counselors
but it was always kind of,
that's really how the
simple equal outcomes over the last
couple of years,
more and more studies and more and more
research
started to come specifically following
counts to give more specific help with some
studies that showed
that for some areas, for example,
depression, the very clinical outcomes,
not how people feel, not what people say
The way you can measure their depression
symptoms, the
improved the reduction in these symptoms
is somewhat increasing
online counseling with platform like Better Help
compared to traditional counseling
so as this get more acceptable by people
in more back by my research
that's definitely going to help you
but I'm not I don't think I can actually
predict what happens
at 20 years from now,
but I don't think we're going to be 100% virtual
Yeah
even in this time
Alon before we end,
Three words that describe you
well,
that's the reaction
Yeah
You should've prepared me for that
but then I to get that reaction
three words, they has to be three adjectives or,
whatever you come up with
it's not a commandment
three words that you feel now
trying my best
love it
I might adopt that I really like it
Alon thank you so much for your time
thank you
there's a lot of fun
Bye bye